Naturally,
I have to start this week by talking
about the horrific attacks in Paris a
few days ago.
Sadly,
it seems to me that these attacks are
becoming all too common these days and
each event continues in the path of
carnage and absolute savagery these
Islamic extremists want to impose on the
Western world.
Yeah,
I did say Islamic extremist there.
I know that upset some and makes the
politically correct crowd uncomfortable,
but unfortunately the more we ignore the
very set of ideas these people tell us
that they're using to attack us,
the more we actually strengthened them.
This is what my former guests
marginalized told me he refers to as the
voldemort effect.
Jk Rowling described this idea in the
Harry Potter books as quote,
fear of a name only increases fear of a
thing itself.
Are there any other ideas we should be
afraid of talking about?
I can't think of any and I refuse to
treat this one idea differently.
We can't be afraid of scary things,
especially in idea form because that's
how they will grow and morph right in
front of our eyes and of course by
saying these people who committed these
specific horrific acts,
whereas alarmist extremist,
it obviously doesn't condemn all
Muslims.
If at this point you can understand that
distinction,
perhaps there's a cat video out there
better suited for you than what we're
doing here.
I've mentioned a couple of weeks ago how
I'd like to move a bit away from talking
about the regressive left.
While I still want to do that.
I feel like the regressives are a lot
like the mafia.
The more I try to get out,
the more they pull me back.
In.
Case in point,
the response by many of the regressives
immediately after the attacks was to
blame us.
Foreign policy rationalizing,
we ourselves are to blame for the people
who chose to murder over 100 innocent
civilians.
After talking to my last two guests,
Douglas Murray and Feisal site,
all Matar,
I've come to believe this is an
incredibly dangerous and egotistical
lead driven view of the world to the
regressives.
Everything revolves around us.
People only do things as a reaction to
us,
so even though these terrorists say
they're doing this in the name of
religion and point to the actual texts,
they approve it well according to the
regressives,
they just don't know what they're
talking about.
That said,
as mentioned,
and as I've been saying repeatedly to
things can be true at once.
It can be true that there is an ideology
out there,
a book written by men a long time ago
that gives plenty of reasons to kill all
infidels,
and at the same time it can be true.
Our western foreign policy created
massive instability in their part of the
world and perhaps if we left it on the
power,
isis never would have arose.
Every action leads to consequences.
Often unintended ones.
Sometimes America does good things.
Sometimes America does bad things,
but thinking it's all about us,
all of the time seems more like how a
child would think of the world than how
an adult would approach the problem.
Of course,
none of this will stop the regressives
from laying blame solely on America and
it's allies thus emboldening,
both the extremists themselves and those
on the far right.
I've been trying to have discussions on
this show so people can see that there
are others out there who understand the
nuance and complexity of these very
difficult issues.
We don't have all the answers,
but we aren't afraid to have the
conversations that most people won't
touch.
Let's pretend for a second that all of
the world's issues.
We're a hundred percent because of
America and we did exactly whatever it
is isis would want us to do.
Would that make us any safer?
Actually,
I'm pretty sure we do the exact opposite
by holding the Western world in a
perpetual hostage crisis with the same
people who have an old text to justify
adjust to that final thought on this.
I'm really not trying to score cheap
political points here by constantly
calling out the regressive.
I'm trying to lay out a case to show you
guys that the left is in real danger
because of the regressives misguided
head in the sand,
politically correct brand of
demagoguery.
At the end of the day,
I blame these attacks on nobody other
than the sick,
twisted people who committed these
horrific acts of violence.
At the same time,
I won't stop speaking up against the
misguided ideas that will only bring
about more of these acts because we are
afraid to look at the whole picture and
not just our narrow,
myopic view of the world.
My guest this week is Sarah Haider.
Sarah is the cofounder of ex Muslims of
North America,
an organization which advocates for the
acceptance of religious dissent,
promote secular values and aims to
reduce discrimination of those who leave
Islam.
Also,
according to her twitter bio,
she is Pakistani by birth and American
by choice.
Sarah,
welcome to the show.
Thank you for having me here today.
It's really good to be here,
so I'm so glad we finally connected
because we've been going back and forth
for a couple of months and we seem to be
sorta swimming in the same circles,
so to speak lately,
and I love that line.
Let's just start with that line on your
twitter bio,
Pakistani by birth and American by
choice.
Why did you put that in there?
Well,
I,
well,
in a lot of people don't know about me
is that I am an immigrant.
Um,
and I think that's a big part of my
story.
And in addition,
I think that the American by choice
means a lot because there are so many
things about America that I love.
There are so many values that are,
uh,
that are truly American that I think
are,
are wonderful.
And in so many left wing circles,
it's unfashionable to say anything
positive about America at all.
And I hope to be able to swim against
that tide a little bit.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure that as an immigrant
that's doing good things in this
country,
you're allowed to maybe kind of say
something nice about America.
Are you a neo con now?
It was apparently if you ask certain
people I am,
but uh,
I think that,
you know,
it took me so long to be able to get
this citizenship.
I only got it this year and now I am
fully an American citizen and I feel so
happy about it because this is a country
I know so much about and I've spent my
entire,
you know,
most of my life here and I feel so
strongly that I am part of the American
fabric and I want to contribute to it
however I can.
Yeah.
Well obviously I love all that.
And where I really became familiar with
you was back in May when you gave this
speech at the American Humanist
Association,
which was really brilliant stuff.
But I want to start first with a little
bit of your history.
When did you and your family come here
from Pakistan?
When did you sort of have your secular
awakening,
that kind of thing?
Well,
uh,
I think I was about eight years old when
I came to America and I remember,
I remember this being a very strange and
new country for me.
I remember learning the language and I
remember thinking it was very strange.
Um,
I,
I struggled a little bit in the first
few years,
but then there was so much about America
that I thought was just wonderful and I
mean these concepts that we have that we
take for granted,
like,
you know,
individual liberty and right to free
speech and all these things.
I mean,
these don't exist in any form in so many
parts of the world.
So as that we have it,
you know,
and I saw this with new eyes and hey,
here you can say anything.
I mean not anything truly but in a way
that in a way that isn't just comparable
to anywhere else.
And uh,
so anyway,
I became really immersed into American
government and I thought it was really
wonderful the way that,
you know,
the separation of powers,
the bill of rights.
I thought that was just fantastic stuff.
And when I was about 16,
15 years old,
uh,
I began to have doubts about my faith
and a lot of it had to do with actually
a,
I mean,
just debating and seeing new viewpoints.
I was on the debate team that helped,
uh,
what did push me a little bit,
I think was meeting a,
what you would call a militant atheists,
you know,
the obnoxious,
the worst,
those militant atheist violence,
right?
And the people that get in your face.
And,
and there was one guy in particular,
I know a few,
but there was one guy in particular who
would print out verses from the Koran
that were just horrible,
right?
These horrible verses.
And he would just hand them to me and
not say a word and just be like,
this is,
look at this.
And you know,
this was my first time really,
really looking into it.
And I think this is the case for so many
Christians and Jews and Muslims who
leave religion that they were like,
well,
you know,
when I really looked into it,
it didn't make a lot of sense.
Or there were some horrible stuff in
there,
and for me it was kind of a quest to
prove these atheist wrong,
you know,
and uh,
I started doing research online because
I was sure that,
that Islam was the way and as long was
so good for women and women's rights and
all of this stuff could be explained
when looked into context.
And then I looked at the context,
sometimes I made things worse.
So then I thought,
okay,
well it's time to admit defeat.
And it didn't really take me a long time
before I thought,
this just doesn't make any sense and
it's not honest for me to say that I am
a Muslim.
Given that I know all of this now.
Yeah.
I love that you described the militant
atheist.
What did they have?
They had photocopied paper that was,
that was their weapon.
You know what I mean?
The other extremists,
they have some more serious stuff.
Like,
you're going to get a paper cut.
That's pretty much going to be the worst
thing that's going to happen to you.
Right.
And it's just,
it's amazing.
To me that's all I had.
That's all that it took,
really is just here,
this was what you believe.
This is the book,
this is your holy book,
this all the drug.
Yeah.
So when,
when they showed you that and you looked
at this was your family,
like how religious was your family?
How did your process of coming out,
you know,
I've described this process that
atheists have to come out of the closet,
much like lgbt people do,
that there is this hidden shame,
this feeling of the otherness and all
that.
How long did that take before you had
the realization versus when you told
your family,
your friends,
that kind of thing?
Well,
so as far as that terminology,
that coming out thing that's so common
in Muslim circles,
that's,
that's what we used was that have you
come out to your like,
you know,
do,
are you out of the closet?
That is the language that we use because
that's the.
That's the reality of it,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Well,
what I,
what I did was I drew just have debates
with my family here and there about
specific issues and that's how they sort
of got the message.
I don't know if I explicitly said it for
the first couple of years,
um,
but I was lucky.
I'm very lucky in that I have a truly
liberal father and by liberal I mean,
okay.
I still wasn't allowed to wear certain
kinds of clothing.
Right.
I still couldn't wear shorts in the
house,
I still couldn't have boyfriends or
anything like that or date.
And I was expected to get an arranged
marriage and everything.
Wait,
where's the liberal part coming?
It's coming,
but that's,
that's liberal.
It's liberal in the sense that he
allowed me to.
My father allowed me to read what I
wanted to read and he didn't question it
too much because he thought I would end
up in the right place at the end.
So that was a sense of freedom and I
only had to fight for maybe a year or
two to be able to go away for college.
So that was,
that was my liberal father.
Got It.
So funny how it's so funny how terms and
words really mean a lot,
you know,
before you refer to,
as you say something nice about America,
the left will say you're a neocon.
And in,
and in this context you described your
liberal father,
but you know,
you couldn't wear shorts and that kind
of stuff.
And yet clearly within that space he was
liberal.
It's amazing.
It was very liberal and he was very
liberal in the sense that he,
he gave me a sort of dignity as,
as a woman that I think that wasn't
given.
It isn't given by many Muslim men to
their daughters and to their wives and
mothers.
And so I,
I consider myself lucky.
I,
I know that sounds interesting,
but I do consider myself very lucky that
my childhood was,
it was similar to maybe what very
conservative almost fundamentalist
Christians would have and that I
consider myself lucky that I didn't,
I wasn't forced to wear the hijab.
I did wear it for a short amount of time
by choice.
Um,
but it wasn't forced upon me.
so it is,
it is interesting what we consider
liberal and what's considered liberal
anywhere else in the.
Yeah.
And that's one of the interesting things
and one of the reasons why I wanted to
talk to you because you know,
there are so many stories you hear
about,
you know,
x Christians leaving,
you hear about ecs,
Jews leaving,
you know,
Orthodox Judaism,
something like that were there then
considered heroes on the left.
They left this dogmatic conservative
ideology,
but you don't hear about many people
like you and I've recently connected
with a bunch and it's like you're so
obviously standing up for the basic
liberal values that we all talk about
all the time.
Right.
It's,
it's so bizarre to be in this space.
I mean,
I feel strange that I'm here because I
feel like we have enemies,
like people who just don't like what I'm
saying for one reason or another.
And my narrative is a,
it's a,
like you said,
a classical liberal one and it's
something that on the face of it,
should it be something every liberal
should support.
But there is,
there is such a tendency on the left to
protect Muslims,
uh,
to protect them from bigotry and these
fears of bigotry I would say.
I mean,
they're,
they're real right there.
It's not a,
it's not,
they're not making this up.
It is,
it is a fear and it's a real fear.
Uh,
but the response has been what I would
call a reactionary.
It's interesting because they say the
reactionary,
right.
And I think what would be your response
to Islam is also very reactionary.
You're also not looking at it from an
objective point of view.
Yeah.
Well it seems to me we've got the
reactionary right and the regressive
left.
But I want to hold that for a second
because I want to talk about the speech
that you gave because it was really
wonderful and I saw a blowing up on
twitter and a zillion people were
sending it to me and I watched it again
yesterday in preparation for this.
And you know,
we talk about this coming out process,
but I,
you sort of referenced that in this.
It seemed to me like,
obviously without knowing you,
and this is the first time we spoke,
but it seemed like your entire life had
led up to that very moment.
Am I being very dramatic there?
Um,
well I.
It was something that I was extremely
nervous doing it.
I mean,
and I don't know,
I think it showed in the video that I
showed that I was nervous and I was
because I felt um,
ever since I've been doing this activism
now it's been three years that I've been
doing x Muslim activism.
I am blind sided by the reaction of the
left.
I really thought,
you know,
and this is something that I hear from
activists everywhere I hear that they
thought they would come here and they
will talk to people on the left and they
would find allies.
I would find people who are willing to
support them and we're willing to give
at least moral support if not anything
else,
but they would find their brothers.
And I found it in so many ways.
People I considered my brothers and my
sisters in the struggle.
I have overlooked me for what seems like
a very political,
very,
very political reason and the,
what I was feeling,
um,
especially around the time I was giving
that speech,
it was after the Charlie Hebdo shootings
and I was feeling extremely disheartened
by the sec,
even the secular community overall that
there are so many people that were
saying,
well,
you know,
they,
that in some ways it can be justified
and Islamophobia,
Islamophobia and all this stuff.
It didn't really make a lot of sense and
I was feeling abandoned and so I
thought,
you know,
they gave me this opportunity to have
the speech,
so I'm going to just speak my mind.
I think maybe they expected me to talk a
little bit more,
mostly about my organization,
but I ended up sort of hijacking that
conversation and talking about that.
Yeah.
Well,
first off,
I mean I recommend that everyone that's
watching this should absolutely watch
that because we can only touch on some
of what you,
what you did there,
but the reaction from the left,
uh,
you know,
it's a lot of what we've spent this show
talking about and the more that I try to
get away from it,
you know,
I've tried to address it so that I could
move away from it.
I want these people to understand that
someone like you,
but someone like me,
that we are standing up for liberal
values,
but it's not just that they've ignored
you in a lot of ways.
These people have sort of actively tried
to undermined you,
don't you think?
Right?
And then there is.
It's not just undermining,
its,
its sliming.
Right?
And there's people that have questioned
my agenda and what am I,
what am I doing this for?
I mean,
I don't know,
I don't,
I'm not gaining anything from this.
I mean in,
in,
in a lot of ways this comes at a high
personal cost and I think many Muslims
that speak out.
Um,
but there are so many people that are,
that are very intent on painting me as a
right wing show and I get this all the
time and I even get this from people who
I thought would be my allies from
atheists,
from leftists.
Um,
so it's
that tactic,
just that general tactic that it's not
about what you say because if anyone was
to listen to that speech or hopefully
anything that we're going to talk about
here,
I'm going to guess that you're going to
line up with liberal values 99 percent
of the time.
So it's rarely about what you say.
It's about who you are and that you
don't fit into their neat little box of,
of what a Muslim should believe.
Which is crazy to me.
Well,
I actually disagree with it.
I think it is what you say in the sense
that if you're talking negatively about
Islam at all,
at all,
on any perspective,
it is better if you're fueled by human
rights are fueled by bigotry,
whatever.
It doesn't matter if you are touching
negatively on Islam on any level,
you are a bigot matter how you say it
because a lot of people say this to me.
They say,
well,
what would you tell you know,
Richard Dawkins,
Sam Harris,
you know,
I think there's a way they can say their
critique a that would be beneficial and
what I tell them is,
or when I ask them instead is,
well,
can you think of somebody who has
directly a critique Islam and in a
direct way that has gotten away with it
that hasn't been called a bigot by some,
you know,
how do you,
how,
what is the right way of saying this
point me to an example of somebody who's
critiquing Islam and it has been able
to,
you know,
get away and still retain their liberal
credentials.
Yeah.
And that's the part of this that drives
me nuts because,
you know,
when I started the show only a couple
months ago,
my intention was not to talk about this
stuff this much,
but as I said,
I can't get out of it because as a
liberal I see people like you and I say
this is,
this is the very people,
regardless of your religion,
if you were an ex Christian,
as I said,
or if you were an issue,
I would feel the same way about the
principles that you're standing up for.
So,
you know,
I,
I laid out some principles when we
started the show that I wasn't going to
talk about people that much specific
people except in this space.
There have been a couple people that
have,
have acted really,
really dishonesty and I read just a
couple of days ago a piece that you
wrote about some of the stuff that Reza
Aslan has said and I find him to be a
profoundly dishonest player in this
space.
And I see what he's done to Sam Harris.
Most of my audience knows about all of
that already.
Can you explain a little bit about what
your,
what your stuff is with him?
Well,
so this was,
um,
in response to,
I wrote,
I co wrote a piece with Muhammad,
say who's also works with ex Muslims in
North America.
Uh,
there was,
there a CNN clip that's been going
around and it's making rounds again.
I have the CNN clip where Reza Aslan is
on and he talks about fgm and he talks
about Bill Maher and it talks about how
a fgm isn't an,
isn't a Muslim problem.
It's an African problem.
Okay.
Female genital mutilation,
we should just say it for the few people
that may not,
right?
Yeah.
And he and he,
and then he,
um,
he puts a few other things out there,
uh,
as evidence that I'm Muslim.
Majority countries are actually not that
bad for women.
Uh,
including,
you know,
there are some women that are heads of
state and et Cetera.
Um,
so I wrote a piece about it.
A Co wrote a piece about it and publish
it on the friendly atheist and it got
this big response because I feel like
there were some people that,
a good amount of people that were
wanting somebody to pick up on these
things that they felt like weren't true,
but they couldn't say this and we said
it and we laid it out there and we laid
it out very clearly about why the points
that he was making were dishonest at
the,
you know,
at the least.
And I think in a lot of ways he's aware
of what he's doing.
So he said,
he said many times that,
um,
you know,
Mohammed,
he said something to the extent of how
Mohammed freed the slaves.
He said things in that vein quite a few
times and they're just extremely
dishonest.
That is not true.
It's just not true.
I'm,
all Mohammed did was say that you can't
enslave another Muslim.
And there are many people,
many scholars who think that this
actually encouraged the spread of the
slave trade because suddenly you're in
Arabia and you can't slave enslave
another Muslim.
So you have to go out and you have
record on,
you have to go to various places to get
your slaves.
He did that.
He didn't condemn slavery.
He had slaves,
he had sex slaves and so there.
And supposedly Reza Aslan is a scholar.
Uh,
I don't even know about that whole
thing.
I can't,
I can't waste any more brain cells on
that guy basically.
Right.
It's just so it's,
it's very frustrating.
And talking about Reza,
Aslan,
I'm getting tired of it myself just to
see that,
oh,
he's just,
he just make stuff up sometimes.
Do you think that's part of the reason I
wanted to mention it because I knew you
were going to be exhausted by talking
about it because it's like you write
your piece and then you want to move on.
And that's how I felt a lot with a lot
of my interviews.
I interviewed Sam and I wanted to move
on to some other stuff,
but then these guys just further the
attack.
But do you think that that's part of it?
That they throw out what I would call
just basic bullshit,
or they throw out these lies in these
smears and then you have to spend a
tremendous amount of your time and your
energy and your life force basically
either defending yourself or,
or the honest critiques that you're
making.
Absolutely.
And I think this is the experience of,
of almost everyone who has critique
Islam in any way in which is why we're
seeing that there's just a lack of it.
There's just a lack of it everywhere.
I mean there's a lack of scholarship if
you try to,
to really study this.
And I have,
um,
there,
there isn't that much out there that is
truly secular,
that is looking at it from a very
outsider's perspective.
Um,
there were some efforts to do so,
but they've now been painted as
orientalist and therefore bad and
therefore right wing of course.
So,
and so there's,
that study sort of stopped around the
time that those smears began.
Um,
and those associations with this
bigotry,
if you're going to conflate this with
any kind of negative,
any kind of negative anything.
Um,
so it's,
I think it's,
it's really unfortunate because a
scholarly pursuit of looking into,
you know,
what Islam is,
how did it begin,
what Muhammad did,
all of that.
I mean,
that has just,
it's suffered,
it's suffered tremendously because of
people's fears of being seen as a bigot,
racist,
whatever.
So a lot of,
I think a lot of people haven't,
haven't really reached out,
haven't really said the things that they
want to say,
reveal the knowledge that they had or
even looked into it further if they want
it to,
because if they're thinking,
well,
this is going to destroy my career.
What's the point?
Yeah,
and doesn't some of that,
that fear of speaking out about this
stuff,
doesn't that actually show what real
bigotry is?
If you're afraid to speak out about
something because you think it's going
to lead to dishonest smearing of you,
or really what it's about is violence to
you.
That's what people clearly are really
afraid.
I mean,
I get emails now every day literally
from all over the world that people are
afraid to speak out.
So the real bigotry is saying we're not
going to talk about these people because
guess what,
they can't control their violent
tendencies or something like that.
Right.
All right.
Well,
it's interesting because a lot of people
said this about,
about the Charlie Hebdo cartoonists.
They said,
well,
they should've seen it coming
that John Kerry,
John Kerry,
our secretary of state just in the last
day or so,
said basically,
you know,
there was some sort of rationalization.
It's unbelievable.
It's absolutely unbelievable.
And to say that,
that you have it coming when you were
exercising a right exercising or right.
That is given to you in the country that
you live in.
What's the point of having a right.
If I can't test it to its extremes,
that's the point.
And in a lot of ways what Charlie Hebdo
did for example,
was not that extreme,
um,
it,
it was exactly the same treatment that
they were giving Christianity and they
were giving that exact same treatment
to,
to Islam.
So to me it seemed like they were,
they were making it fair.
There were saying that,
hey,
we're not biased and we're gonna apply
the same,
the same scrutiny to all religious
forums,
and they did that and I thought they
were very fair about it and then they
smeared in so many ways.
Yeah.
And not only did they do it out of a
quality where they made fun of Orthodox
Jews and made fun of Christianity.
I think I'm going to slightly butcher
this,
but I think it was something like 80
percent were about Christianity when
they did cover is related to religion
and only something like 10 percent we're
about Islam.
Uh,
but um,
I don't quote me fully on that,
but also what people fail to realize
with Charlie Hebdo is that it was satire
about the things that are wrong with
religion.
They weren't mocking Muslims as people
adjust as they weren't mocking
Christians as people,
but they were mocking archaic age old
ideas.
Right,
right.
Absolutely.
And in many ways I think it can be seen
as an anti racist publication and,
and a lot of people made a lot of good
cases for this.
And it's difficult because we're English
speaking people and we don't really
understand the context of how,
how they,
how,
you know,
these publishers do what they do in
France.
But I think when you look at it from an,
from a very unbiased perspective,
you'll find it.
There are anti racist in lot of ways and
it was horrible to hear people say,
well they had it coming because it,
it made it seem not only that they were
stupid for doing what they're doing
instead of brave,
which is what they were,
but,
but also that Muslims are beasts and
animals and we cannot expect them to
behave in the same way we would expect
everyone else to behave.
Right then.
That's what I mean about this sort of
soft.
I think this is what Bill Maher refers
to as the soft bigotry of low
expectations.
If you say anything about these people
that's going to upset them,
well then you have to just expect that
they're going to kill you and that
that's crazy.
And also you would live in a constant
hostage crisis with a certain set of the
population.
Absolutely.
And that's,
I mean,
that's exactly the feeling of I think a
lot of those people who tell you that,
you know,
I'm afraid to speak out,
it it,
it is absolutely taking away from the
humanity and Muslims too because it's
turning them into beasts that we cannot.
We cannot say,
hey,
this is a standard that we expect from
everybody.
We expect you to be able to handle this
and that they listen to it.
And I,
we actually haven't pushed it.
We actually haven't said that,
hey,
this is totally acceptable and this is
totally what,
how we run things in the western world
and this is what we expect out of
everyone who is here in the Western
world.
We expect you to respect this,
especially not respond in a violent way.
And I haven't had that conversation.
So is part of it simply that for the
people that are the real Islamic
extremist,
they simply,
at the end of the day,
no matter how much my friends on the
left want to blame everything on
American foreign policy and all of this
stuff.
No matter,
you know,
Boko Haram killed about 160 people last
week.
It had nothing to do with American
foreign policy,
right?
Um,
yet this is,
they always blame everything on America
and I don't deny,
as I said at the top of show,
I don't deny that foreign policy is
mocked up a lot of things,
but this is where people on the left
just completely fail.
Right?
Absolutely.
And I'm,
I'm very,
I'm sick of hearing that colonialism is
to blame for all of this.
I'm sick of that one particular thing I
hear all the time that this is,
it's because of colonialism and it
doesn't really make any sense when you
look into it.
And again,
not to say,
not to say that it colonialism wasn't a
horrible,
horrible practice.
I mean I'm from the South Asian sub
continent so we were colonized by
England and it was horrible what England
did to,
to South Asia and the effects,
the long range effects it had on South
Asia,
but there are just so easy to throw away
the colonialism excuse when it comes to
radical Islam.
I mean,
I mentioned two of these in my speech,
which is that,
uh,
Muslims have been doing this sort of
thing,
violence,
justifying violence in the name of
religion since way before colonialism
ever came into the picture,
right?
That it's existed for a long,
long time.
And when you say colonialism was the
only thing to blame,
you are denying that that whole history
existed.
But there were so many people that were
oppressed in the name of Islam.
It's happened before and it's happening
again.
It's the same sort of thing.
Yeah.
Did you by any chance see a piece that
feisal site on the tire put up a couple
of days ago on facebook where he,
he writes sort of a satirical piece
saying that he's,
he's playing this,
this Muslim extremists saying,
this is why I'm doing it.
I'm doing it for religion.
And it's basically this argument with
him and one of these regressive left
these saying,
no,
it's not because of religion.
And he keeps saying,
no,
no.
I'm doing it because of religion.
And they go back and forth and going
back and forth and at the end of the
guys like,
you know,
what do I have to do to prove to you
that this is in the name of religion?
I mean,
even after Paris,
which I want to talk to you about in a
second,
the statement that these guys issued,
there was a lot of religious overtones
to it,
a ton of religious overtones.
It wasn't purely,
you know,
this bombing in Syria or whatever.
Well,
it's,
I mean,
it's astounding to me that at this point
anyone can deny that religion has
nothing to do with it.
I try.
I believe that every,
that there was no one really,
uh,
any serious intellectual will believe
that this has nothing to do with
religion.
It has something you know,
and you can even make the case that it's
a perverted Islam,
but it is some aspect of Islamic
theology that they have taken and then
perverted at the very least,
at the very least that they have done
that.
And I think that a lot of people play
just lip service.
They say that this has nothing to do
with the religion.
I don't think they believe it.
I think this is in a lot of ways,
a very political move.
Yeah,
so I mentioned this also at the top of
the show,
but if let's say magically the United
States and the West and and France and
England and everybody,
we all did whatever it is isis wants us
to do.
You know what I mean?
Pull out of that part of the world.
Whatever else they might want us to do.
Do you have any reason to believe that
suddenly terror would stop or that
things would get better?
I actually would see it completely the
reverse.
They would own most be more to continue
and I say that as someone that doesn't
even want to be there in the first.
Right.
I,
I agree with you.
I started,
isis is a different animal and if they
are,
they are very strict about their
interpretation and they look into things
at,
in a very literal way and if they are
going to look into it as a,
in the way that,
you know,
Islamic thought has progressed about
what you would call the land of the most
of the believers in Atlanta,
the nonbelievers,
they are religiously.
It's a duty,
so religious duty to do what they can to
spread Islam to at the whole globe.
So they're not going to stop us there,
told us they're not going to stop.
Why can't we just listen to them and
understand that they mean what they say?
Yeah.
And that was the point of fizzles a
piece.
And I got into a fight on twitter.
I try not to fight on twitter,
but I got into a fight with one of my
friends on the left who kept saying
foreign policy.
And I kept saying,
listen to what they're saying,
don't listen to me.
Listen,
listen to what they tell you.
Um,
so one more,
I just want to jump back a little bit
before we get into,
into Paris.
So I want people to understand there's a
distinction between someone like
yourself that you consider yourself an
ex Muslim.
You are a nonbeliever versus some of the
reformers that are still either either
believers or that consider themselves
Muslims.
Someone like imagine new eyes.
Although he said to me that,
you know,
he doesn't want to put up his version of
Islam for anyone else but,
but there is a distinction there.
So there's two brands of people that
we're talking about that are trying to
help here.
Right?
Do you mean like progressive Muslims
and,
and.
Well meaning meaning that there is,
there's your branch that's sort of ex
Muslims,
right?
You fully,
you are an atheist,
you don't consider yourself part of the
religion versus there are some that are
trying to reform the religion from the
inside is,
is there any sort of interplay with you
guys?
Are Our people working together?
It's hard to tell.
Well,
I think that,
I think it would be intellectually
dishonest for us to work together in the
sense that truly our aims are different.
Yeah,
I mean they're,
they're similar in some ways,
right?
We want to make sure that we want to
decrease harm in the world.
We want to push a secondary result and
push human rights,
uh,
promoted the best we can.
But our ways of going about it are so
radically different that I think that it
would be.
I mean,
we're,
I'm in contact with some of these people
and I respect them tremendously.
You're doing wonderful things.
I disagreed with them.
There is,
there is very little about Islam and the
fundamentals of Islam as a Sam Harris
says that I agree with on any level and
it's hard for me to find any beauty or,
or,
you know,
compassion or all these wonderful things
that we would ascribe to something so
holy.
I don't,
I don't find that in this text.
So there isn't really.
I disagree with people when they do say
that I'm a little bit extremist,
you know,
people say that,
well,
you cannot expect everyone to just a
apostatize all at once,
but this is not what I'm pushing.
I'm,
I don't want them to somewhere else who
apostatize all at once,
but for me it would be intellectually
dishonest to Google about it on any
other way.
And I actually think that there is,
I mean,
it's atheism and secularism and
rethought.
I think we have a very strong critique
of religion,
something that is very internally
coherent and ethically coherent.
Um,
and this case is one worth making.
And if we're talking about the
marketplace of ideas,
it's important that we show our side and
we put the best case out there and the
land where they'll land.
So that,
that's really interesting to me.
So in a weird way,
your,
your brand here is a little,
is a little cleaner,
let's say.
Then the people that are trying to
reform it from the inside,
and I don't sense that you're judging
them for that as much as it really is
easier to make a case from your position
because you're just saying,
I don't believe in thousand year old
books,
so I'm going to make a case based on the
world as it is sort of and they're still
trying to negotiate and that's what I
see someone like Reza and where I say
he.
This is someone who's profoundly
dishonest all the time,
but I think he's trying to negotiate the
world with this religion and then it
uses a lot of words so nobody knows what
he's talking about,
but your case is a lot cleaner.
Even even if I disagreed with you,
I would understand the logic more
sensibly.
I do think that in the case of somebody
like Raza,
I think it is condescending towards
other Muslims because I think some
people believe that.
You know,
Muslims will never get there.
They'll never get to where you are.
You're expecting too much.
I don't think I'm expecting too much.
I think this is actually.
If I was allowed to make this case,
most Muslims do not hear anything
similar to what I have to say.
They will never hear anything like this.
I think if they did,
I think it would change things,
but they,
we don't know yet.
Right.
And we don't,
we don't know that that's the case.
Right.
Well now you did this show with me.
They're going to say you're working with
a Zionist Nazi and not.
I don't know if this is going to help
now either.
Tell me a little bit about being a woman
in this space because you have a double,
a double edge sword,
so to speak here because leaving a
religion,
any religion stuff but particularly
tough to leave Islam.
And then when you couple that with all
the stuff related to being a woman and
being a secular woman in America in
2015,
isn't that easy sometimes a,
how does that play into how you,
how you live?
Um,
well let me start by saying there's so
many people that I'm connected to
through my,
through the organization and through
meeting a bunch of ex Muslims.
I mean,
I didn't,
I don't think it'd be a stretch to say
that I probably know more ex Muslims
then most people in the world now will
ever know,
but,
and,
and what I,
what I hear consistently from a lot of
women that the reason that they left the
religion,
it was because of the treatment of women
and a lot of it just didn't make any
sense and they didn't,
they didn't appreciate.
They felt that they weren't being given
the same kind of dignity as,
as men.
And when they looked at it from that
perspective,
things changed.
Feminism has to do with it,
which is very interesting.
Why don't we talk about today is
feminism here,
but really found the feminist allies in
the West that I thought I would find I
expected to for them to be the first
people to run to my defense.
And a few have but a small few.
Um,
I ha.
I expected there to be a big rally with
the feminists from all over to come and
talk about these issues,
but I haven't found that to be the case
at all.
It's very disheartening.
Yeah.
So what is that strange alliance because
you see this all the time,
you know,
a group like code pink that stands for
women's rights and antiwar,
you would think they would be standing
for women's rights all over the globe,
but instead they'll rant and rave and
talk about Gaza.
Meanwhile,
if they ever went to Gaza,
I'm pretty sure that these women would
not be treated particularly well.
So this double standard just endlessly
exists,
Huh?
Yeah,
absolutely.
And I,
I think it's,
it's,
it's very,
like I said,
it's disheartening for one and because I
was somebody that,
that feminism was a huge part of me
leaving religion.
It was a huge part of me,
a fueling me and the women's rights
causes a fueling me into my activism.
It's been especially painful to see that
feminists are not always on my,
uh,
on,
on the same level as me.
But I have found is that there's a lot
of posts about women that say the Muslim
women that say that they're empowered by
the hijab,
you know,
and there'll be,
there'll be on feminist west websites.
They'll say,
you know,
I'm very empowered by this job and it's
my political whatever,
and you know,
to me it's,
it's wonderful for that particular
woman.
If she feels that this is her choice and
this is what she wants to do and this is
how she wants to live her life,
that's great,
but a Muslim woman that's wearing the
hijab up,
making a piece like that is like a woman
in Nineteen Thirties America saying that
I'm proud to be a housewife.
I love staying home with my children.
This is exactly where I want to be.
Well,
good for you.
Maybe you do and that's wonderful.
It's good for you that everything in
society aligned with your desire.
Perfect thing.
Oh you and now you get to live this
wonderful life,
but you have to acknowledge the 19
thirties America women who may be
wanting to have a career weren't as free
to do so that there were so many
different factors that were making it
very,
very difficult for them to live the life
the way they wanted to.
You have to be able to acknowledge that
and then same way I want these hijabi
women to be able to acknowledge that,
hey,
there's so many women who don't ascribe
to these modesty codes and they aren't
free to live lives the way they want.
Well,
and this again,
this is why the left has put themselves
in the regressive left,
is put themselves in such a crazy box.
They should be defending women's
options.
They don't have to say you have to live
a certain way,
but they should at least give you the
options and that's also why they have
been relentless on new atheists.
So you get it.
Now as a woman,
you get it as an ex Muslim.
I don't know if you identify
specifically with the new atheist with
new atheism,
you consider yourself a new atheist.
What does that even mean?
I'm not sure exactly.
Nobody.
Nobody really seems to know.
The best way I can describe it now as
our,
at least as I've come to understand it,
is that it's an atheist who is finally
speaking up.
So for that,
for that version,
that's what I would consider myself.
Um,
but,
but community,
the left really has been attacking
atheist too,
so you're on a,
like a year,
like spinning and you got shot from all
sides.
Huh?
I,
I definitely feel that way.
I mean,
I don't want to talk about how big of a
victim I am because I don't like those
kinds of politics,
but,
but in general,
I have felt that the people that on
paper should be supporting me.
Um,
and I looked into this actually as a
response to seeing the way that leftists
have reacted.
I've started to do more research on what
liberal principles were and really
trying to get a grounding on what it
meant to be a liberal.
And I feel under Bill Morris said this
so many times.
He said,
I the real liberal and I think he's
right.
He's right.
When he says he's a real liberal and I
feel like I'm a real liberal.
Yeah.
So you're not gross and racist.
That's what you're telling me.
Oh God,
that was so bad.
That was so bad and honest.
Okay,
here's,
here's what I was watching that I kind
of felt I'm going to get haters to this,
but it kind of or been Africa little
bit.
I kind of thought,
oh,
it's cute that he's standing up.
He thinks he's standing up for the poor,
oppressed minority.
Right.
That's what he thinks he's doing.
That's what he's really convinced that
he's standing up for an oppressed group
and it's nice that he has good
intentions,
but it's nice.
I appreciate that,
but he's so wrong and he's really
hurting these same minorities and he's
not understanding exactly what's going
on here.
And it was very interesting in that
particular scenario to see Sam and then
very emotional,
very,
very emotional.
Ben Affleck and very calm Sam Harris.
You know,
I think you'll find this interesting.
I was discussing this with,
well first off I discussed it with Sam
himself,
but I also discussed it with Joe Rogan a
couple of weeks ago on his show and I
said,
what you just said.
I said,
well,
you know,
I think he was trying to do the right
thing and trying to.
And maybe he got too emotional,
but you know,
he was trying to stand up for the down
trodden,
that kind of thing.
And Joe said something that I now fully
believe.
I mean,
he got me to change my opinion like
that.
He said,
no,
he's like,
man,
I know actors,
I'm around actors.
They fate this so that everyone will
just think they're so holy there.
So benevolent.
They're so wonderful and all that.
And,
and he was really convinced that that's
what Ben was doing there.
But I don't,
I don't want to waste anymore.
A lot more time on that specifically.
Um,
so the atheist stuff,
yeah,
you're getting,
you're getting it from them,
you're getting it from the other guys.
What can we do then what,
what can secular people and free
thinkers do?
Because I know that people just by
listening to this,
a certain subset of people are going to
say all the things that you laid out at
the beginning,
they're going to say that I hate
Muslims.
That you're a secret Zionist.
All of this nonsense.
But what can we do?
I guess just talk,
right?
I mean,
it's really that the best we can do
so I think just be intellectually honest
and I think that a lot of people
understand what I mean when I say that
because people stop themselves.
They want to say these things.
They have these opinions and the
reaction that I got to my speech at the
American Humanist Association,
the biggest reaction was you said what I
wanted to say you.
You put the words that I was thinking in
my head,
but I just felt like I couldn't.
I really couldn't articulate and I felt
trapped and you said those things.
So it felt like a release,
you know,
for,
for me to hear you say it for to hear
somebody say it and I think that if we
can be brave and if we can talk about it
and especially liberals,
it is very important that it is liberals
who stand up for this because we were
the compassionate ones,
right?
Where the,
that really are keeping the harm of that
of the people in place.
We are not forgetting about anti Muslim
bigotry.
That is something that is,
that is obviously at the forefront of
our minds.
We know that because that's why we're
not saying anything about this,
of this harm,
so it is those,
particularly those people that need to
be speaking about the need to be making
this nuance discussion.
Right,
and that's what it seems so obvious to
me that I don't have to twist my beliefs
to say the things that I'm saying to
you.
Everything that I'm saying to you and I
sense everything that you're saying to
me is based in the same set of secular
principles that you apply to everything
else and for some reason these guys want
you to just be a little more careful
when it comes to this set of ideas.
But what I see as the real danger there
is that if we don't speak up right now
and we're editing,
we're an extremely precarious moment
right now with everything going on in
Paris and with Isis and all that.
That if we don't speak up,
we hand the future to the people on the
right.
Absolutely.
They're.
They're getting empowered by this
because people are not stupid.
We are seeing that there is this big
elephant in the room that people we
cannot talk about,
that the media isn't talking about,
what are we doing?
We're building distrust of your average
American citizen when they're watching
their TV screens and they're not seeing
anybody but Fox News really talking
about Islam in a way that,
that feels remotely honest and it's
horrible.
It's horrible that we're,
we're giving this up to these people who
really have some Zena phobic motives.
Maybe the,
you know,
and we need to make sure that it is us
that are talking about this,
that are engaging with this issue.
You can,
it's similar to I think what happened
with the tea party.
Um,
I think there was some real hurt and
some real pain right after the economic
downturn.
And I think a lot of people were feeling
abandoned by their government and I
think we could have,
I even say now we could have seized on
that moment and we could have made it a
populist progressive movement to take
down,
you know,
corporations or whatever it is we could
have.
We could have harnessed it,
but instead we disdain those people
because they were,
you know,
backwater bigots,
whatever,
people who were very uncommon that they
don't understand things in a nuanced,
complicated way the way that everyone
else does.
And so we find it very easy to,
uh,
to,
to just push them aside and dismiss them
and look at what happened there.
Right?
They became a political force that a lot
of people would say had done some harm
political spectrum.
So we don't want that happening again.
Yeah.
I don't know if you saw my video about
it a couple of weeks ago,
but I said that the regressive left is
our tea party and I don't want what has
happened to the right that has been
dragged off the deep.
I don't want that happening to my side.
That's why I do think we're at this
moment.
Um,
so I know we only have a little bit
left,
but I do want to focus on Paris a little
bit.
I know you're not a,
you're not a terrorist,
a expert or something of that nature.
Um,
but in terms of the,
the human part of this,
that it sounds like a lot of these
people did grow up in Paris or in
France.
They grew up in the west,
some of them grew up in Belgium,
but they grew up in western societies.
Um,
what do you make of that kind of
radicalization because,
you know,
I know a lot of the debate right now is
about can we let refugees in,
are we going to let terrorists in with
refugees in that?
But there's also a home grown grown
problem right now that we're not dealing
with.
Yeah.
This is my,
and just my opinion,
and again,
I'm not a scholar on this,
but I feel like there are many young
people in different parts of Europe
especially,
and I think you were particularly that
feel that they are.
And a lot of people say they're between
two cultures.
That's the phrase that people use at
there between this western culture and
their culture back home.
But I don't think that that's the truth.
I think that the truth is that they
don't really have any.
They don't really have any viable
options.
They don't really believe in the same
stuff that their parents might have done
from Pakistan or whatever and they don't
really fit in with the community in the
west and they sort of feel lost by this
multiculturalists narrative.
Right?
That if we can push a and then in a lot
of people do have a specific critique,
they say that we have lost our bearings,
we have lost our values,
we don't really push our story and our
values and our,
you know,
and on our way of looking at the world.
We don't really advocate for that in the
way that it deserves to be advocated for
and I think these are the people that
are there,
the lost children of.
Because these are people who don't have
anything so they don't have anything to
latch onto.
What they do have to latch onto is it
somebody comes and says this,
Islam is narrow and everything makes so
much sense and it's.
Everything is so clear now and they can
grapple onto it.
I think you've covered this so many
times.
You've talked about this,
about freedom of speech issues,
about how we're not allowed to talk
about certain ideas.
I think it's so harmful that we're not
allowed to talk about critique of
religion,
critique of Islam,
because we're then we're giving up this
ground to,
to the Islamists were letting them give
these people,
these are the,
these great narratives that they'll
latch onto and they don't have any
opposing narrative at all.
Yeah.
So,
so what do we do?
I mean,
really what are the secular is do I know
that there are some organizations like
the one that module is involved in that
are trying to deradicalize people,
show them that there's other out and,
and I'm with you.
I get it,
that it's,
it's a compounding of economic issues
and,
and religious narrative and imperial.
It's all of these things.
Um,
but how do we move forward because the
talking as we're doing,
it's good for now,
but at some point we got to get to
these,
to the kids.
I guess they're the younger generation.
Well,
this is something I,
you could get is related to the Syrian
refugees are coming in,
a lot of people are very worried about
the effect that these refugees will have
on the countries and I think the only
longterm way of proceeding and making
sure that we don't have these same kinds
of problems is to push emergent as much
as we can,
which means that we don't allow them to
build these isolated little communities.
We spread them out within a,
within the country and we pull them in
into the American way of life or Western
way of life.
What have you.
Um,
in that sense,
I think a lot of these multicultural
narratives are very,
very,
very harmful.
I think we need to discard them
immediately.
There's a lot of this.
Uh,
there was a lot of hesitancy.
We know,
we know how to pull immigrants in and
how to immerse them into our,
our study.
We know that there is so much.
There was so much work about this and
scholarly stuff about this written about
this.
We can do it.
We're a nation of immigrants.
They want it to right.
Every one of us,
every one of us here in America,
we either are from immigrants or we were
brought over as slaves or were native
Americans,
but the large majority of us are
immigrants.
Right.
And,
and you know what?
Because what happened was America pulled
us in and said,
well here's the stuff I don't like,
but here's the stuff I do like.
And they pulled it together and we
became this nation that is so powerful.
And then what you have instead in places
like the UK,
is it these many nations that are not a
part of the overall,
you know,
Britain,
British society,
there's little Pakistani community and a
little north African Community and they
sort of live as if there were back in
Pakistan or Bangladesh or whatever it
is.
And that I think is so harmful because
these people never feel like everyone
else.
I feel like an American and I don't
think everyone else does and I want them
to feel that way.
I want them to feel like an American.
Yeah.
It's an interesting.
It's almost like a self fulfilling
prophecy because then when,
when the British people go in and try
and go move into that community,
then they feel like those people in that
community feel like they're under attack
or something or they have to defend
their little area.
So you have this constant battle of,
you know,
uh,
of the self versus the bigger community.
Yeah.
And what,
what has happened is that we've given up
the battle,
right?
We've just said,
okay,
we'll just live however you want to
live.
You're just different people and you
just operate on different rules and you
have different concepts of human rights
and that's just,
we're just going to turn a blind eye.
That's what's happened in the UK I
think.
Yeah.
And we can't do it anymore,
right?
No,
we have to have these.
I mean we've always had with these
immigrant communities in the United
States,
these negotiations,
these back and forths with these
scuffles and sometimes I've been very
painful,
but in the end we're stronger and the
immigrant community gets immersed and
it's stronger too.
Yeah.
Alright.
So my final thought would be A.
I've been trying to end all my
conversations on,
on a note of positiveness,
uh,
and I think you've actually given a lot
of hope throughout here,
but I definitely sense that the tide is
turning.
I know it feels like a dangerous time
right now.
There's so much craziness going on and
with the Internet,
everything feels smaller.
So when something happens 5,000
miles away,
it seems like it happened in your
backyard.
But I do send something good here.
The fact that we've,
the fact that all of these people,
now that we're all in the same circles
and we're all talking and our circles
are getting bigger,
uh,
I do feel like maybe the tide will turn
in our favor.
Do you,
do you feel that.
Give me something good to end down here.
I think you're absolutely right.
You've mentioned this before.
I noticed that things are changing and I
feel this and I think marginalized.
I've said it to before where you said
the left is changing and he feels this.
You can sort of be it in the air,
that there is discontent there,
that there's people were suddenly.
There's a lot of dissonance going on
people's minds and we want it to make
sense and I think that we're giving,
you know,
this point of view that we're giving is
one that is so much more clear and it's
so much better for people and better for
humanity and I think people will,
will slowly gravitate towards it.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny,
I did a video on free speech last week
at night,
at the end I referenced,
you know,
all of this stuff we say safe spaces and
trigger warnings and all of this
nonsense and it's like when I speak to
someone like you and I speak to them an
and ion and Sam at all,
you'd be,
like I said in the video,
I was like,
look guys,
watch my videos with these people.
If you think these are the extremists,
then there's something wrong with you.
It's not something wrong with them.
You know,
my June Sam just wrote a book called
Islam in the future of tolerance.
It wasn't called Islam and the future
of,
you know,
weapons of mass destruction,
you know?
Uh,
anyway.
Well,
it's an absolute pleasure.
I'm so glad we connected and we're able
to do this and you're doing such great
work.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much for having me.
Yeah,
so it's at Sarah the hater on twitter
and everyone should check out your
group,
which is ex Muslims of North America and
we're going to stay in the loop and the
next time you know La Dinner's on me.
Alright.
Thanks a lot Tara.